[Musique]
martin biron michel ces objets luc
ferrandez bonsoir
on va revoir ces images de cette grosse
structure blanche au centre-ville de
montréal que beaucoup et pas remis et
vous beaucoup n'aiment pas en disant on
va défigurer le centre-ville ans la
voilà elle n'existera pas c'est terminé
mais le projet russie recommence à zéro
on va parler mais d'abord je fais
écouter madame plantes et monsieur
legault en conférence de presse
malgré tous les efforts qui ont été
déployés hier demeure pas moins qu'ils
ont un secteur qui était problématique
d'un centre ville on était devant une
impasse c'est le cas de le dire qui à la
lecture du rapport des experts c'était
clair pour moi mais c'est aussi clair
pour mon équipe que le tronçon en aérien
dans le centre ville c'était une erreur
historique qu'il fallait absolument
éviter de faire
quant à elle vint le tronçon au centre
ville on eu des discussions avec les
dirigeants de la caisse de dépôt ça
change beaucoup le projet pour la caisse
de dépôt parce que eux comptaient pour
investir 10 milliards sur une
rentabilité du projet de l'est jusqu'au
centre-ville en enlevant le bout du
centre-ville en proposant je parlais
tantôt de d'autres changements ben euh
ne veulent pas poursuivre dans le projet
je les comprends
je les comprends pas il a été assez
transparente sur le go easy la caisse a
dit si vous enlevez le tronçon
centre-ville ce projet là ne tient plus
debout parce qu'il ne sera pas rentable
économiquement rentable parce que les
gens vont aller sur la ligne verte pour
aller au centre-ville et il ya moins de
kilométrage pour la caisse mais aussi
moins de facilité faut quand même le
dire pour les gens de l'ess d'aller aux
entrevues tour de table martin est ce
que c'était un accident qui était prévu
depuis quelques semaines qu'elle
arrivait ça faisait un moment que l'on
commencé à discuter de trouver des
différentes solutions le gouvernement
avait d'ailleurs mis en place un comité
d'experts l'quipe au vraiment
décisionnel que pauvre vraiment pris
part à la décision mais quand même on
voyait que le projet devait être vus de
toute façon le gouvernement avait pas
vraiment le choix laisse quand même
dans le centre ville les gens on voulait
pas ça devient difficile de forcer un
projet aussi énorme je souligne en
passant que
cet axe là ce
axa axa est rien ce tronçon à érié passe
dans des circonscriptions francophones
quand même à quelques mois des élections
alors le gouvernement dit bah écoutez on
va virer bord le projet bien honnêtement
ils ont gardé leur carte série
très très très proche tout le long de
ces discussions là là ça fait à peu près
un mois look qui tue en coulisses le bon
vous dites les gens ne voulaient pas du
tronçon est rien
enfin il ya beaucoup de gens qui en
voulait pas oui c'est vrai ce que les
gens ne voulaient pas si ç'avait été
efficaces nous le serons jamais chelsea
au jort que vous vous étiez parmi ceux
qui dans vos analyses étaient très
critiques face à ce projet la
wii et y'a rien qui vaut de défigurer le
boulevard lévesque sur quelques
kilomètres au centre-ville de montréal
ça n'avait pas de bon sens c'est ça qui
a fait bloc et à la ville de montréal et
à partir de ce moment là la caisse qui
avait fait un trafic qui dédouble et la
ligne verte du métro faut pas l'oublier
quand un cas la chambre de commerce de
l'est nous qui orne eure plus d'accès
direct non vous avez fait un petit
passage de durée mots au métro se sera
pas extraordinairement compliqué là et
il y aurait une guerre qu'on demande à
personne de les faire venir j'avais mais
excusez moi monsieur je vais revenir
avec sa après tu est ce qu'un jour il y
aura un vrai lien parce que d autres
régions auront un lien direct entre eux
mais il ya de vrais leviers c'est un
petit strasbourg demain qui n'est pas
très important alors un moment 2000
c'est ça se fait bien le caecum comme
traverser l'île il ya des groupes si
vous marchez sur le clip de trades joué
en marchant c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça voilà nuque
mais moi ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
vu un gouvernement changé
il s'est obstiné mais là il a tenté des
choses là la dernière mouture qui était
proposée pour rené lévesque était
extraordinairement ambitieux ça coupait
la moitié des voies de circulation
moi je me réjouissais de ça mais quand
même c'est énorme ensuite il y avait
cette espèce d'esplanade qui a été créé
il y avait des larges trottoirs ils ont
été très loin pour essayer de faire
passer le projet bravo mais ça n'a pas
suffi et comme cela ne suffisait pas là
la solution c'était de dire aux robes
ranchi leur et m sur la ligne verte
parce que michel raison a de dire des
principaux défauts ce projet là c'était
qu'il y terre parallèle avec la ligne
verte à partir de honoré beaugrand à peu
près jusqu'au centre ville un métro ça
coûte un milliard de voix on veut le
mettre voilà on voit là si le projet
sera prêt d'honneur est beau grand et il
y aura un crochet à faire et les gens
pourront aller au centre-ville mais les
la prétention de la caisse c'est à dire
qu'avec les gens que c'est la terrible
fallait voir sur 15 20 ans luc michel et
martine que la ligne verte était et elle
est saturée de toute façon mais bon je
peux donc c'est une bonne question parce
que pour que la ligne verte ne soit pas
saturé il faudrait rajouter des trains
est rajouté des trains c'est un gros
cool c'est un coût qui se compte en
milliards de dollars au moins un
milliard de dollars donc c'est pour ce
n'est pas rien de dire on va la
connecter sur la ligne verte et sa part
plus de wagons et ensuite il ya cette
question de fréquence
avoir ouvert la fréquence maximale on
est on est pas un africain
bon on va s'y rendre en ajoutant
détruits sur le terrain plus politique
vous l'avez dit martin en est à six mois
d'une campagne électorale la mairesse
n'étais pas confortable avec cette
portion du centre-ville c'est une
évidence n'était pas confortable avec la
place qu'on lui avait donné autour de la
table à la cdpq infra donc monsieur
legault s'est dit dans le fond la
mairesse le veut pas il ya des gens
qu'ils veulent pas ça coûte une fortune
on arrête tout ça quoi c'est fait c'est
plus facile stopper le train maintenant
web mais en fait il a passé le message
qu'il tient à avoir un rêve de lestang
évidemment il ya pointe aux trembles
il veut avoir quelque chose pour les
gens de l'extérieur il voyait votre
devoir trouver une solution le pour le
tronçon notre dame pour se rendre
complètement dans l'est mais il ya quand
même des conséquences c'est à cette
décision là aujourd'hui parce que c'est
une grosse nouvelle laisse quand même un
projet 10 milliards de dollars et il n'y
a pas donné beaucoup de réponses aux
conséquences de son geste d'aujourd'hui
d'abord il va y avoir des compensations
que le gouvernement devra verser à la
caisse de dépôt et seysses et peau
mouillée le tue sa réserve et après les
élections l'autre affaire c'est que bon
on efface tout et on recommence le
nouveau projet l on devait livrer en
2029 quant à eux plus de projets c'est
ça la réalité c'était 10 milliards là
est ce qu'on s'en va vers 12 milliards
est-ce qu'un jour ce projet là va voir
le jour la voie celle à terme celle ci
quand martin dit on recommence à zéro
mais je vous soumets que l' expertise
cpq intro pelli trouver un peu
bulldozers passez moi l'expression mais
ils ont développé une expertise énorme
là on a mis ça du transport la ville de
montréal la stm puis la rtm pour qui les
a tous un comité avec beaucoup de monde
vous y croyez michel pour vrai un projet
de l'ess vers le centre ville bientôt
c'est qu'être uc4 groupe d'hommes
beaucoup plus d'expertisé que la caisse
de dépôt en termes de transports en
commun puisque
ça c'est la première des choses et
deuxièmement ça c'est des vrais joueurs
donc alors si s'entendre est une map ils
peuvent s'entendre pas de problème c'est
pas compliqué de voir ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant parce
qu'effectivement ils vont avoir les
plats de la caisse de dépôt et de les
adapter c'est pas extraordinairement
compliquée après ça c'est du cde du
vouloir c'est notre argent sata
lequel vous aussi optimiste que mon ami
michel
jeu je précise donc premièrement c'était
un projet bo au bild on dénombrerait par
la cades la caisse ça veut dire ils
financent une construit ce qu'il opère
la stm est capable d'opérer une ligne de
métro ou une ligne de transport aérien
totalement aucun problème est capable de
construire n en ferait la démonstration
vous êtes en train de construire le
garage bellechasse années de terminer le
garage crémazie des gros bobos garage
tout un demi milliard de dollars elle va
concevoir la ligne bleue elle a
construit le métro de montréal elle est
capable de faire la différence
maintenant c'est le cynisme l'ins tm a
jamais financiers un projet la caisse
arrivé avec ses milliards de jeux le
financier mais cette forme de 18 %
pendant 100 ans hélas et de gouvernement
du québec a fait un calcul puis a dit je
suis capable d'imprimer des milliards de
la caisse je veux les faire moi-même mes
propres emprunts sur les marchés
internationaux et ça va marcher ça vont
coûter moins cher que 8 % par an centre
il ya une dernière chose que la caisse
faisait pstn la rtm de font passer de la
captation de la valeur foncière c'est
lorsqu'on construit proches des gares la
caisse va chercher grâce une gare au
centre-ville à 500 mètres de dakar
sombre et d'une valeur une partie de la
valeur foncière
donc je repose la question là où la
chambre de commerce de l'est qui se
désole aujourd'hui est ce que on va voir
c'était 2029 le projet peut-être se
répéter 2029 mais c'était l'objectif
est-ce qu'on va avoir d'ici 2030 2035
2033 je sais pas un projet réalisé pour
relier la seule région qui ne l'est pas
actuellement vers le centre-ville l'est
de montréal tour de table martin
parr long de la ligne bleue je pense que
j'ai passé ma vie active à entendre
parler de la ligne bleue
les toujours pas fait le troisième lien
a été repoussée d'un an et là on arrive
avec ce projet là moi je suis moins
optimiste que michel effectivement s'ils
se mettent au travail et qu'ils arrivent
avec un projet c'est bien ficelé très
rapidement au bureau du premier ministre
on parler d'une question de mois et non
pas d'années avant d'arriver avec un
nouveau projet et qu'on trouve le moyen
de le financer le financement actuel qui
étaient sur la table pour leur mc 25%
québec 25% ottawa et 50% caisse de dépôt
alors il va falloir refaire le
le montage financier ben oui le ca
pourrais
ça risque d'être comme tout grands
travaux il ya des retards alors michel
vous dites ils vont se mettre à
l'ouvragé avec les études déjà fait bien
sûr de la caisse puis vont trouver puis
vont ils vont entrer sur la ligne verte
puis merci bonsoir
ils partent pas de zéro ils partent de
chaussures déjà été fait et pour le
reste la stm sait comment faire le
problème dans l'est de montréal c'est
qu'on a le syndrome des bleus le
problème de langue lui c'est qu'elle
était premier genre 4 5 fois et que le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu donner son
financement l'affairé s'était soldée la
raison pour laquelle ça n'a pas marché
si à la volonté politique du
gouvernement de financer ça a été assez
clair aujourd'hui samos faire s'ils
décident qu'ils font comme la ligue
bleue aux puces
est ce que c'était un manque de notre
part je parle collectivement
d'imagination de voir quelque chose qui
aurait pu marcher avec une structure
surélevée sur rené lévesque
luc pas impossible que ce soit un manque
d'imagination
peut-être qu'une fois construit on
aurait dit ah c'est pas si grave c'est
pas si mal c'est pas impossible mais il
n'y avait pas que ça il y avait le
financement c'était trop cher le
premièrement c'était trop cher à 8%
pendant ce temps c'était trop cher
deuxièmement
ce chevauchement avec la ligne verte ça
faisait pas de sens on peut pas avoir un
métro coûte un milliard de la station
père quotidien coûte 400 millions de la
station rouler un côté de l'autre
pendant plusieurs kilomètres ça faisait
pas de sens non alors on va suivre ça je
sais pas est ce que je serais toujours
là quand va annoncer concrètement ce
projet là pour l'est de montréal mais
disons que
patrick oui patrice oui patrice peut
permettre à lire en théorie ça devrait
aller plus vite que le projet durable
que deux projets de cdpq parce que prend
la section il n'y a pas la branche
centre ville en théorie ça peut aller
plus vite d'accord en théorie tous de
trouver des leviers de la gamme
oui vous êtes résolument
optimiste moi j'ai trop d'exemples la
voie réservée de pin heures vous déjà
ils savent comment enfin il ya des
affaires qui arrivait jamais qui devait
arriver est bon la caisse oui dégageait
oui bonne dose ie les je crois qu'ils
ont mais je poste un phélizon ils ont
développé une expertise malgré tout
énorme mais vous n'êtes pas d'accord
michel je veux bien qu'on me laisse les
jeunes enfants n'oubliez pas la donne a
changé des médecins du mali à chaque
nouveau gouvernement il y avait
quelqu'un qui est juste et quelque chose
pour lui il faut que ce soit des charges
sur ce que c'est jean-michel l'on parle
de développer vers la nadière aussi vers
l'aval vas-y mon
premier
ministre c'est exactement là où la
chicane fauconnier la ville de montréal
va vouloir qu'à partir de marie-victorin
saraiva rivière des prairies pour
desservir les quartiers nord est le
gouvernement du québec et le reste c est
meme pas vouloir que ça traverse pour
aller à laval et là ce sont des terres
agricoles alors gros faire faut faire
très attention au type de développement
qu'on va faire aussi à laval et si ça va
se faire à laval ou à regarder plus
belle réunion en vue avec tous ces
experts merci beaucoup à vous trois
merci
après la merci au revoir la prochaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh